starting with my delicious mushroom and
leek pasta
this fantastic fast and simple pasta
dish made with everyday ingredients just
goes to prove you can eat good food
whenever you want
really important put the water on first
so you can just have it gently simmering
away ready for the pasta
while the water comes to the boil start
the sauce by slicing mushrooms first off
fingers
one in front two behind
up and down
then add olive oil to a hot frying pan
[Music]
i want that nice color on the mushrooms
off the heat literally 10 seconds
and when you toss something really
important you get all the ingredients at
the end of the pan
push down and pull back
that noise that
that's all the water coming out of the
mushrooms
next finely chop a fat clove of garlic
[Music]
then prepare your leeks
just take your knife
and go down through the center turn it
over
and again into quarters
see all that opening up and then just
rinse the top of that to get rid of any
potential dirt or sand
it just breaks up into nice little
quarters
add
all that leak
into those mushrooms
beautiful
and now
the secret is to get rid of that water
inside the leek
as it cooks down all the water's gone
you just left that really nice intense
flavor
garlic's got nice and crispy now we're
gonna add a touch of chicken stock in
there
beautiful
lasagna sheets just gonna drop the
sheets
in to the water
lasagna sheets are an unusual choice for
a dish like this but they work
brilliantly although any type of pasta
you've got in the cupboard will do
and just twist that pan
that stops any pasta actually sticking
to the bottom of the pan
chicken start to reduce down by half
and it's almost delayed the bottom of
the pan basically washed all that
wonderful flavor off turn the gas down
and add a couple of tablespoons of cream
this just enriches the dish bring it
back up to the bowl and let it simmer
for three to four minutes
now
the secret with the pasta is just taking
it out a little early
so you've got that nice texture
hold up the sheet and just nip it
and you can feel your fingers in the
center it's ready
turn the sauce down and lay
these beautiful sheets
of lasagna into that sauce
i'm just going to turn the gas off now
and let the pasta sit in there and
absorb that amazing sauce
finish with chopped fresh tarragon
it's a delicious herb it goes
brilliantly well mushrooms and leeks
just let that sit and almost sort of
infuse
to serve i'm making a quick bruschetta
by toasting fresh chipata bread two nice
slices drizzle that
in olive oil
a little bit of garlic
just rub the bread
the crust as well crust is what really
takes that garlic
now pan for the bread a little touch of
olive oil
as it starts to smoke
bread in
[Music]
but look at the pasta now it's been
stained by that amazing sauce to serve i
want a nice spoon of my mushrooms leeks
and cream then i'll take my pasta
just twist it
and let it sit on top
that tarragon has just lifted everything
bread on
and that's the beauty about something so
simple that can be done in 20 minutes
with everyday ingredients a stunning
pasta dish
adding easy and versatile dishes like
this to your repertoire is what cooking
at home is all about so my next tasty
dish uses simple and cheap store covered
ingredients with stunning results and
takes minutes to make
sweet corn fritters and yogurt dip
it's brilliant to have a number of great
recipes up your sleeve to rely on and
let's be honest we've all got a tin of
sweetcorn somewhere so i'm going to show
you how to make the most amazing fritter
[Music]
first off the mixture
take your flour sieve
really important to sieve the flour that
stops the mixture from having any lumps
in there
just before you get to the end
i want to put
half a teaspoon of baking powder the
baking powder gives the mixture some
lift
in
and just sieve that through
a touch of salt
and pepper
next an egg about four tablespoons
of milk
and give that a little whisk
now just put a little drizzle
of olive oil in there that helps to
relax the mixture
whisk that in make sure we got rid of
all those lumps
so that i want a nice smooth
almost like a cake mixture okay next
take the seeds out of a chili to lower
the heat roll the chilli so give it a
really good
shake
[Music]
tap them out
slice
in half
into quarter
and each quarter
in half
and chop through
it's a really nice quick way of slicing
a chili
into the mixture spring onion
take off that outside layer of the
spring onion top and tail slice it in an
angle
it's a little bit of texture running
through the mixture i want that nice
crunch in coriander
just slice through
nice and gently
and get that in there
next to the sweetcorn now drain it from
the tin and just pat it dry so it
doesn't make the mixture too wet
give that a nice mix
you can see now i've got two thirds
ingredients and one third of the mixture
to bind together that's the secret of a
good freitas so you're
you're biting into excitement not sort
of dough
pan on
olive oil in
nice and hot
get a nice big dessert spoon you know
there's one nice portion
in space the fritters evenly around the
pan in a clockwise direction so you
always know which one to turn first
just with the back of your spoon sort of
spread them out a little bit
okay
palette knife
just check
and happy with the color
and turn over
beautiful
now for the chili yogurt dressing
deseed and finely chop a red chili
and add to a pot of natural yogurt
and then
some fresh lime
[Music]
finish with chopped coriander
coriander in
and give that
a nice mix up
that chilli just lifts it
the lime gives it that nice tanginess
the fritters
they smell amazing and with the sauce
it tastes fantastic
that is such a delicious recipe using a
tin of sweet corn from your cupboard
amazing
stir fry with rice noodles
some of the best street food i've ever
eaten was in asia every one of those
little markets was filled with smells of
delicious food that all centered around
an asian staple noodles learned to cook
those properly and you'll be surprised
how quick and easy it is to knock off a
delicious dinner
first off we're gonna soak our noodles
now these are rice noodles into a bowl
and just pour the hot water
over the rice noodles
soak
and rehydrate
12 to 15 minutes to soften up if you've
got a wok perfect if not just a normal
size frying pan with big sloping sides
pan on
get it really nice and hot
chicken breast very lean hardly any fat
on there you've got this little fillet
just slice that off
now the secret to getting it really nice
and thin
and to cut it into strips
take your knife
keep it nice and flat on the board and
sort of slice it in half like a sort of
scallop
like that
we call this butterfly in the chicken
take a rolling pin
and nice and gently roll over the
chicken what it does it sort of flattens
it allows you to slice it
even thinner
and the thinner the slices of the
chicken
the sort of crispier it gets the quicker
it cooks
slice it in half
start slicing
these nice
thin slices and the good news is one
chicken breast can serve two or three
easily
next wash your knife and finely slice
garlic
the thinner the garlic
the crispier
this is a
young
tender broccoli just slice them down
i want a bite to the broccoli
and normally you sort of paste the dish
with one-third noodles one-third
vegetables and one-third of your protein
chicken
with a dish that takes literally minutes
to put together it's really important to
get everything organized everything
needs to be at your fingertips
touch
of olive oil
get a pan really nice and ready just
starting to smoke
drop the chicken in first
salt pepper
open up those little strands of chicken
nice
[Music]
once you've started to sear off the
chicken
get the garlic in
now let that get really nice and crispy
the way to do it is to sort of spread
all the chicken the garlic up the side
of the pan
and see why it's so important to cut the
chicken thin strips because it colors
and cooks at the same time as well
really really crucial
now that garlic's getting really nice
and crispy broccoli in
feels strange putting raw broccoli
in like that normally
we'll blanch it in boiling water dry it
out but
you want that crunch
now soy sauce that helps to season it
but also stains beautifully soy sauce in
lovely
it's exactly what i want now take that
out
give you a pan a little wipe out
a little teaspoon of olive oil get that
wok really nicely oiled again
drain your noodles
they're beautiful
this is a really exciting way of
finishing
this quick stir fry very classic two
eggs
in
[Music]
whisk up the eggs
and give that a really good whisk
[Music]
sort of
almost spread it
at the side of the pan
lightly season
the eggs
noodles
in
chicken and broccoli in
[Music]
and give that
a really nice mix
you want the egg to sort of almost
bring the dish together
that egg's cooked
make sure you've got that nice
even distribution of
chicken
broccoli
garlic
[Music]
lovely and then just finish that fresh
lime
and then you have a very
simple
delicious stir-fry with rice noodles
[Music]
you